j'ai déposé récemment une proposition de
loi euh à la Commission de l'aménagement
du territoire et du développement
durable la semaine dernière sur le
bureau du Sénat euh afin de de trouver
une solution durable pour la
problématique des sargases sur nos
territoires ça voir la Martinique la
Guadeloupe mais aussi la Guyane si en
Guyane c'est le secteur de la pêche qui
est touché en Guadeloupe c'est tout le
littoral euh qui est touché et aussi à
Martinique et ça pose énormément de
problèmes non seulement sur l'économie
de ces territoirees mais aussi sur la
santé de nos populations puisque vous le
savez euh les sargas dégagent de
l'ammoniaque dégage du clore sulfuré et
c'est un véritable je veux dire désastre
pour l'économie puisque les commerces
sont obligés de fermer face à cela il y
a eu des demandes depuis 2012 pour des
déclaré sur l'état de catastrophe
naturelle pour ces territoire les
différents gouvernements sont restés
sous puisque on
nous répond que le caractère de
prévisibilité n est pas le code
d'assuranciel ne rentre pas en compte
par conséquent il fallait passer à une
vitesse supérieure alors la proposition
de loi consiste en quoi déjà de modifier
le CE de l'environnement rajouter un
article qui ferait que c'est l'État sur
les végétau marins qui puisse prendre en
charge ces phénomènes là totalement et
que les sgaces doivent être récupérés en
mer pour éviter l'échouage et la
décontamination sur les sites quand ces
sgas là touchent le littoral donc un
ramassage en mer donc de la
responsabilité au cas où il y aurait
défaillance de l'État et quelques sargas
arrivverait sur le littoral et bien là
aussi ce serait de la responsabilité de
l'État en mobilisant les l'armée en
mobilisant toutes les forces nécessaires
pour pouvoir les ramasser et en cela
nous demandons aussi qu'il y ait une
coopération beaucoup plus intense une
coopération internationale pour mettre
en place le principe du pollueur payur
parce que nous savons la provenance de
cesargas c'est au Brésil donc nous
demandons aussi dans le cadre de de
cette rois à une coopération
internationale poussée euh pour faire
entendre la voix de de de la France dans
le cadre de la préservation de
l'environnement euh sur dans les milieux
euh euh plus précisément dans les
milieux aquatiques